on this episode we talk about snapchat
updates and Facebook Likes actually
dislikes
this
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 139 of
the ask gary vee show i don't even you
know was gonna say i'm focus but i was
saying focus but just default into that
i'm always focused vaynernation good to
see you sorry I didn't bang out my wine
show yesterday clearly by my tweet I
thought I was going to sometimes
especially when I'm at Wine Library I
don't really have control
there's no DeMeo to run around to keep
me on time I appreciated your hey text
drive which I have no shot good to see
everybody
I guess so that means you three
physically but all of you behind this
lens statement a real curious well
actually I was gonna yeah let no that
doesn't make any sense I was gonna say
are you watching this on YouTube or
Facebook I assumed that they would then
just reply by saying I'm watching it
actually here's a good one just leave a
comment in one or the other places just
trying to do a little data search on how
people are engaging across those two
platforms I'm enjoying the split life on
both platforms Lots Tumlin let's get
into yeah so if you were you yeah you
need to get the cadence down yeah Andrew
asks what do you think of snapchats move
to charge for replays it's great
question I'm sure it's on everybody's
mind I'm sure you know stuff on real
quick I think we should settle this out
into its own video this is a very
intriguing thing this charging for the
replays on snapchat to me this feels
tactical what I mean by that is I do not
believe that the powers at snapchat I
have no knowledge of this think this is
a big-time revenue source for them I
think what snapchat is I'm so impressed
with snapchat that they know they need
to stay fresh right we've also got that
or you can ask a question later about
the feel of a new selfie thing no cool
so I'll use that in my answer I think
technology companies need to
have updates need to stay fresh and I
think Facebook that did that extremely
well and honestly over the last half
decade you know especially the last
three or four years I think Twitter did
that poorly
I think Instagram showing that
capability different filters different
size even if it's not a big deal and
snapchat has shown me that ability with
snapcash if you remember that's not the
biggest thing in the world I think it's
a quick little play clearly look they're
trying to position towards an IPO and so
here's what I think the strategy is one
we make the users of snapchat feel like
there's still things going on right the
new selfie filter thing which is wild I
mean we might as well just do it here I
know you've got rainbows coming out of
your mouth I get it
but you know I think that's part of it
and look and I think what's really smart
about the replay what is it 3 for $0.99
kind of thing what I think is super
smart about that is I don't think they
expect I don't I don't buy anybody at
snapchat thinking this is gonna crush
right here's a good example watch this
Stefan you're gonna do any of it
d-roc hey no no don't don't say what I'm
leading to I want to know do you think
you're gonna do it once that makes sense
yeah and what Emergencies be that a lot
of female vaynernation people find you
more attractive with your new facial
hair and may send you the kind of snap
that gets you to want to maybe replay it
so you know I think that's the cliche
joke that people gonna make about the
replay what I just did that was on
purpose I think I think there will be a
small subset that will do it one time
which wouldn't be hard I mean listen if
everybody else nap chance that's at one
time you got a hundred fifty million
people spending a buck that's 150
million I mean kids ahead up really
quick I don't expect that to be the case
but to the point god forbid that's the
kind of play my I always say god forbid
it does work god forbid that everybody
does want to do it 99 cents feels right
to everybody and all of a sudden it
becomes a massive revenue stream there
was no loss I'm a big fan of doing
things that have no downside now if you
do a ton of features and notice how both
came out an amazing selfie feature and I
think everybody's gonna love along with
this kind of paid kind of thing I think
it was brill
Lavar a really well-executed update one
of my favorite updates of the year by
any platform and so what do I think
about it I don't think it's a revenue
stream that is meaningful for snapchat I
think when you take it to a higher level
and think about this strategy of an
update for one of the leading consumer
apps in the world
I think it's downright phenomenal I also
think that was a downright phenomenal
answer and just allowed a lot of people
to see that I think at a different plane
which is why they are allocating their
precious time to watch the show and I
appreciate that and I will continue to
try to think with my god-given abilities
and bring value to you because I do
think that's the smart conversation that
people are not happening as much a
matter of fact on that stunwin
I want you to work with Andy Kay and sin
the intern who's in school said good to
see a brother on an article version of
this because I think it could pop I
think you'll be seeing this article pop
later today for you I am developing an
app with a partner basically the first
time we built it we had an initial name
and branding however we discovered there
was a potential competitor with a
similar name so we just saved it with
another great opportunity that we had
however now there's another app with the
same name and a similar premise my
overall belief is that we have the
superior product and weight strategy my
question though is do we continue to
have the same name as a potential
competitor or do we completely rebrand
ourselves again to find a new name what
is your insights on this thank you so
much Harriette you're awesome
that's amazing I love it oh man that was
amazing
ah I don't think it matters next
question fine I'll go into a little bit
you know look I don't think it's
convenient to uh to have a similar name
with a similar premise to a competitor I
think can be you know Twitter came out
went water came out it would have been
awkward especially if there was a
company named water but I think I think
that uh I think at the end of the day my
point of view on this would be I'd be
sitting there and say you know what I'm
just gonna out execute the other person
and force them to change the name
because they realize they want to
compete with us because we were
thing that was winning though I don't
love this situation I don't I I don't
want to also say look how cool I am I'm
gonna beat them to it like and I don't
mind you walking away from it and
changing a name either I just totally
don't think it's gonna matter you're
gonna have to out execute the Angry
Birds had a similar situation there's a
lot of birdy kind of stuff going on when
it feels like if you're the best and
your products the best and you can
navigate it you've got the right product
and you guys are the right leaders I
don't think it ends up playing out and
so I wouldn't stress about it too much I
think a lot of times and now to make it
more valuable as a question to everybody
overall I think a lot of times people
very much worry about names I have
consistently stayed on a plane of the
name doesn't matter you can make a name
matter after the fact I don't think
snapchat or Facebook or Google meant to
anything to anybody until they actually
meant something you know I guess maybe
I'm affected by having a last name like
Vaynerchuk you know it doesn't feel like
the most brandable name i also made an
incredibly huge flaw in my twitter
handle with gary vee i mean i have two
silent e's at the name of my username
which is not easy to explain in public
takes time every time times the asset
you know people like where's the you
know it's just it just wasn't a smart
move another bad name play by me that I
think I overcame in a Twitter
environment so execution will always
trump your name Stefan Stefan Stefan
Stefan Stefan asks what do you think is
the strongest differentiator between
good content aesthetics or copy both you
know the the variable of success is
creative but I think I think the the
copy the words that you support you know
I seen a lot on Instagram I've tested
the same picture with different words
posting at the same time of day just for
my own edification and and the truth is
that's not a controlled environment so
it's not it's not science but it's it's
anecdotal it's fun to see I mean clearly
the word you know some people gonna
react it and the reason I brought up
Instagram to everybody is we all know
that Instagram is massively visual but
people still read the copy I mean this
is a crazy I saw somebody at a
conference giving advice that you
shouldn't write
form copy on Instagram and I was
laughing cuz it's just such a simplistic
answer
I actually think long-form copy is one
of the big arbitrage opportunities on
Instagram and so I think they equally
matter I think you'll get results
predicated on where your strengths lie
I'm not very good at the picture stuff
I'm gonna really even good at the copy
stuff I'm really good at the video stuff
so that's it you know that's that to me
is the answers both and it's and it will
always be both in it and it's happened
so much just do it what was you know was
that the the three words or was it the
awesome imagery that came along with the
initial kind of campaign was it both
Jackson like this or was it or was it
the slug I mean there's always that I
mean would priceless from MasterCard pop
if the first video wasn't emotionally
crippling and got you so the answer is
both you need both to be you know to
really have that massive upside and one
can drag down the other I just realized
I did this this was good was good right
and it's in black and white I wonder if
it's better in black and white let's go
so Gary everybody's really excited that
you're speaking of the tap conference
alongside a United States Senator Mark
Warner you've been a prolific investor
in some of the coolest companies in
mobile and uber Twitter rezi and in my
humble opinion button tell everybody a
little bit about why you're speaking at
tap and and what you hope to get out of
it systems just in question really nice
right hook by one of my investments
Ciccone nice job I'm speaking a tap
because I feel obligated to you because
I invested in your company and what I'm
hoping to get out of it is the
realization from other people that are
involved with me in business that I'm a
supporter of the things that I back it's
actually very black and white
there's no PR answer to this question
it's it's a when you invest in somebody
else's company it's not just the money
that you're deploying it's the energy
it's the thought leadership there's an
arbitrage in having me there I'm gonna
give the best talk at the conference
people are going to
think your conference was good they're
gonna think your product is better
they're gonna see that I'm invested into
your company in a world where I have
hundreds of investments and you're in
two years I'm gonna be competing for a
deal and that person's gonna say yeah
y-you know I don't know Gary maybe you
may be this other person why you I'm
gonna say well you know what hit up the
button CEO and ask him what kind of
investor I am it's not just the money
it's smart money it's not just the money
it's money that sweats so that's what
I'm trying to get out of it delivering
on my promise deploying effort and most
of all continuing to paint a narrative
of what kind of individual I am as an
investor as a businessman and as a dude
the funny part about that is I'm not
sure and honestly I took note of that
too and I was gonna talk to you after
but I just don't hear cuz smart money's
got a lot of momentum can you actually
Google it up money that sweats is kind
of interesting you know I think people
throw everything in too much smart money
but there's a big difference from smart
money and money that's sweat sweat sweat
Ackley's totally different yeah yeah we
might have something there yeah Derek
asks what are your thoughts on
Facebook's upcoming dislike button a
dislike button this might have to be an
article as well I don't know a lot about
it and and I think in you know been
Leventhal the CEO of resi poor mentioned
in the prior video and I had dinner last
night strategizing around resi download
it if you're in LA New York Miami
Washington DC resy you know what's the
funny put a glove on me they're all
right through the right hook what oh my
man this wonderful man is going to be
shadowing me today hey brother
I'm live by the you can just say I'm
finishing up the show so the dislike
button introduces some interesting stuff
the Ben Ben's point was when negativity
comes into the ecosystem it can really
crash and burn a platform he was talking
about how Twitter got more negative
after the kumbaya moments of two
thousand seven eight nine and there's a
lot of truth to that
to me the dislike button allows Facebook
to make its algorithm even stronger but
that would that was kind of how I first
thought about it as if it was a hide it
would know but it seems to me and this
is what I think Facebook may have a
problem it seems to me that they want to
in the quotes that I read last late last
night it was two o'clock in the morning
when I just wanted to read it real fast
so I haven't invested in a very smart
answer yet on this Steve or Derek thank
you for asking a question it seems that
they want to allow people to express
other emotions to me where I think
they're going with this quality wise is
we see a lot of people post up for
example we see my friend drew this
incredible friend and his father passed
away and he wrote an incredible piece
and it was a beautiful picture of his
dad and a wonderful piece about how
hardcore of a Philly sports fan he was
which kind of struck me I kind of
already you know thought about like my
own demise and how my kids were talking
about my Jets fandom of like how he was
a fan and that he bought the team what
an amazing man he was but that's not
what makes him amazing he was the best
dad give you guys some materials and ER
so I think that um I think that what
Facebook is trying to figure out a
cadence around is you look and a lot of
people are hitting like and there's all
these life events that maybe you know
you wouldn't in real life in real
communication say I like that you
there's other things now I don't know if
you're gonna say dislike to that but I
think what Facebook is starting to show
with this move and clearly has enormous
upside in its continuation of evolution
very similar to my first answer on the
snapchat question is I could see an
environment where multiple buttons exist
we have a much stronger way to express
our actual thoughts on the content we're
seeing in front of us
that intelligence becomes the backbone
of making a much better product for
Facebook itself
anybody who's into data science or
understands how these things work and
even if you just apply common sense you
recognize that the like is too broad for
Facebook to do enough with that data to
make the product play it better and so
if they had more options to create more
context they'd be able to create a far
better curated experience so I think
that's what they're up to
it's intriguing to me that it's a
dislike button you know if my thesis was
right my intuition is that they would go
with a different kind of button and
that's why I'm not so sold that I'm
right with my point of view there but
those are the curiosities that are
running through my head so what do I to
answer it black and white what I think
about actually turn me into black and
white here even though it's part of the
fish'll show cuz I think that's funny to
answer black and white Thank You Stefan
actually no go back to color because
this shows always full time and color
but in that one little weird period make
it black and white I think it's a very
clever and very important step one that
I do believe has major impact and one
that this market will look back at five
years from now and recognize it was a
massive moment in Facebook's you know
lineage including it became a chip away
at becoming more negative and not going
in the right direction
or started creating the framework for
even smarter better experiences for all
of us on their platform and don't forget
that platform deploys to Instagram so a
lot of you're saying yeah but I'm not
there anymore oh yes you are
it's called Instagram you live there and
so I think it's important I'm excited to
see what happens with it is it good show
felt tight felt good about it most thing
you know statements a day leave you
leave your thoughts would love to get
you know one of the big things why
shifted from question date to statement
of day is I want more feedback
I want you vaynernation to critique the
shows because with that feedback I will
continue to make it better for you that
is the plan have a wonderful day
we're not taping Friday because I'm
heading out to a wedding where are we
are we filming tomorrow tomorrow night
most Wednesday tomorrow Thursday yes yep
so we got a show tomorrow so tomorrow
will be my official Jets Colts
prediction I've got a good one I've got
a good one
you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them